في الاثناء اعلن الجيش الاوكراني عن صفقه
تبادل جديده وصفها بالكبيره بينه وبين
الجيش الروسي اطلق بموجبها سراح 116 جنديا
اوكرانيا كما استعاد ثلاثه جثث لمتطوعين
اجانب في صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه وقال
الجيش الاوكراني ان الجنود جميعهم الذين
اطلق سراحهم خدموا في مناطق هيرسون
وماريوبول وباخمت وان ثمانيه منهم كانوا
يعملون لصالح الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه وان
العمل سيتواصل من اجل استعاده كامل الاسرى
الاوكرانيين لدى الجانب الروسي وفق قوله
في المقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
عوده 63 من الاسرى العسكريين في اوكرانيا
واشارت الوزاره الى ان هؤلاء العسكريين
يوجدون حاليا على الاراضي الروسيه وانه
يتم تقديم الدعم الطبي الضروري لهم واضافت
الوزاره ان مجموعه العسكريين الروس المفرج
عنهم هم من الفئه الحساسه حسب وصفها